les ingénieurs et chercheurs du monde
entier se sont lancés un défi et pas
n'importe lequel
probablement l'un des derniers grands
défis technologiques et à y regarder de
plus près c'est même un défi lancé à
l'humanité toute entière
quel est il créer et mettre au point
dans tous les domaines des intelligences
artificielles aux facultés supérieures
aux nôtres
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'ils font du bon boulot
pas une semaine ne passe sans qu'une
nouvelle activité humaine ne soit
automatisé
on pense immédiatement aux exemples les
plus médiatisées au go au poker à la
conduite à l'analyse d'image médical et
des progrès très importants sont
réalisés en matière de compréhension de
textes de sorte que même l'art du débat
est au programme
là vous avez de la donner vous avez de
la place pour l'intelligence
artificielle de sorte que d'une certaine
manière la partie la plus importante en
matière d'intelligence artificielle
revient aussi à s'intéresser à la
question judiciaire puisque comme le dit
la cnil
là où vous avez des algorithmes mais qui
n'ont pas de donner ses algorithmes sont
aveugles
là vous avez de la donner sans algues au
rythme les données sont muettes
si vous avez les deux vous avez de quoi
constituer unia et l'activité judiciaire
la justice n'échappe pas à ces
technologies d'intelligence artificielle
tous les acteurs du procès sont touchés
du juge et partie des magistrats aux
procureurs en passant bien sûr par la
police toutes les phases du procès sont
également touchés est ce que je vous
propose c'est d'explorer ensemble
un procès sous intelligence artificielle
imaginez la scène un groupe d'amis s'est
donné rendez vous en ville pour fêter le
nouvel an
la place est noire de monde et il est
presque minuit à deux pas du groupe
d'amis des échanges furtif mais répétés
ont lieu probablement un trafic de
stupéfiants
un individu manifestement intéressé
s'approche et très vite le ton monte les
insultes fusent
une bagarre éclate sous le coup de
l'alcool et dans la confusion
des coups sont portés les forces de
l'ordre interviennent tout le monde se
disperse
notre homme prend la fuite une personne
reste à terre ensanglanté toute la
question est de savoir si sa fuite lui
permettra d'échapper à son destin
judiciaire
une enquête est ouverte et on cherche à
identifier l'agresseur
les images des caméras de
vidéosurveillance sont analysés
malheureusement elles ne sont pas
directement exploitables on ne parvient
pas à saisir
le taz de l'agresseur et on ne voit pas
nettement
d'où les coups sont venus mais les
enquêteurs disposent d'un outil
d'intelligence artificielle qui va faire
la différence
il leur permet d'analyser les mouvements
des personnes présentes au moment des
faits est de reconstituer leurs
déplacements
le comportement d'un homme se détache et
à plus de 90%
il apparaît que c'est lui qui a porté
les coups sur les images on voit qu'il
porte un plus ouvert reste à savoir à
qui il appartient des prélèvements adn
sont réalisés sur la victime et
l'analyse classique qui consiste à
comparer l'adn prélevé aux adn
enregistrées dans un fichier dédié ne
donne rien il n'y a pas de
correspondance mais les enquêteurs
disposant encore d'une technique qui va
faire la différence
le portrait robot génétique
c'est une sorte de photographie
probabiliste de la personne qui fait
apparaître certaines caractéristiques
physiques la couleur de sa peau de ses
yeux la couleur de ses cheveux et même
son origine biogéographique dans notre
affaire il apparaît que c'est un homme
blanc aux cheveux châtain aux yeux
marrons et détail d'importance avec une
fossette au menton et les oreilles
légèrement décollées et si quelqu'un
dans la salle se reconnaît qu'il se
dénonce immédiatement ça fera avancer
les enquêtes plus vite
des témoins sont entendus les résultats
sont recoupées et on parvient à
identifier un suspect et lors de son
arrestation
on retrouve le plus ouvert de sorte que
c'est notre homme défait 2
volontaire aggravé le sur projet la
victime est à l'hôpital dans un état
grave et il encourt jusqu'à cinq ans de
prison
et puis notre homme est présenté à un
juge qui doit statuer sur son sort le
temps que son procès s'ouvre est
schématiquement il y a deux grandes
possibilités
seul le placer en détention le temps que
son procès s'ouvre soit le maintenir en
liberté et il faut bien voir que cette
décision peut avoir des conséquences
graves sur la personne poursuivie parce
que si elle est placée en détention
elle peut perdre son travail elle peut
perdre son logement et être en
délicatesse vis-à-vis de la garde de ses
enfants et en même temps
cette décision peut prémunir la société
contre un individu dangereux et
sauvegarder la sécurité publique alors
sur quels critères prennent une telle
décision selon le système juridique les
conditions diffèrent mais il ya au moins
deux grands aspects à considérer
d'une part le risque que la personne
commet une nouvelle infraction et
d'autre part le risque qu'elle ne se
présente pas à son procès et les juges
peuvent utiliser des outils
d'intelligence artificielle pour venir
adresser ce risque pour venir prédire le
comportement de la personne poursuivie
et selon les algorithmes utilisés un
certain nombre de facteurs peuvent être
mobilisés l'âge de la personne son sexe
son lieu d'habitation
ces relations son casier judiciaire
son environnement familial plus ou moins
stable ça partial un emploi ou non et
dans notre affaire
il apparaît que notre homme est encore
étudiant il va peu à la fac et ses
résultats sont mauvais il a une petite
amie mais mais rien de sérieux
il vient d'une famille modeste et il vit
dans un quartier où la petite
délinquance est importante
au lycée il a été exclu quelques jours
après une défaite de bagarres et il a
été mêlé à un trafic de stupéfiants
mais faute de preuves il n'a pas été
inquiété en revanche les personnes qui l
ont été inquiétés et condamné pour ce
trafic font toujours partie de ces
relations
ces analyses de sang et d'uriné ont
montré la présence de thc et bien sûr le
soir de l'altercation
il a pris la fuite l'algorithme fixe à
plus de 70 % les chances qu'il commet
une nouvelle infraction et qu'il ne se
présente pas à son procès et son avocat
cherche à combattre ces résultats qui
sont défavorables à son client il
invoque le principe du droit au procès
équitable à l'égalité des armes
il veut connaître les facteurs utilisés
il veut connaître leur pondération et la
base de données sur laquelle
l'algorithme a effectué sa phase
d'apprentissage mais l'algorithme en
question c'est un algorithme
propriétaire et l'axé qui lui est donnée
très limité cet algorithme est
simplement donné en licence à la
juridiction de sorte que son
architecture relève du secret des
affaires
et face à cette impasse son avocat ne
désarment pas et il produit les
résultats de son propre algorithme cette
fois de justice prédictive
il cherche à peser sur la jupe sur la
décision du juge
il parvient à montrer que sur les 15
dernières années et pour des faits
similaires
la majorité des décisions a retenu le
maintien en liberté sorte que l'arène
judiciaire devient le cadre d'un duel
algorithmique et dans ces circonstances
l'appréciation que le juge pour
personnellement sur la sphère reprend
toute sa vigueur
sur cette base la décision tombe l'homme
est placé en détention ne sorte qu'on ne
saura jamais si les prédictions
comportementale qui étaient les siennes
et est juste ou non
après quelques mois son procès s'ouvre
et les débats se concentrent sur la
peine qui doit être juste
car il faut bien sûr le sanctionner pour
les faits qui lui sont reprochés mais en
même temps il faut créer les conditions
de sa réinsertion sociale
c'est la raison pour laquelle la plupart
des systèmes juridiques connaissent un
principe d'individualisation des peines
leur permet de prendre en compte d'une
part les circonstances de la faire et
d'autre part la personnalité de l'auteur
pour fixer une peine et il faut bien
voir que l'infraction polarise la
personne poursuivie au sens où elle est
vue à travers le prisme des faits qui
lui sont reprochés
un vol de l'image d'un voleur une
agression celle d'un agresseur est tout
l'enjeu pour son avocat finalement c'est
de faire émerger une autre image celle
d'un ami d'un frère d'un fils montrer
que notre homme n'est pas réductible à
l'agresseur qu'il fut le temps d'une
nuit
un 31 décembre est habituellement pour
se faire une image aussi précise que
possible de la personnalité de l'auteur
on écoute les questions du juge
les réponses qui sont donnés les
témoignages on écoute les résultats de
l'expertisé sur le profil psychologique
les remarques du procureur et son
réquisitoire
celle des avocats et leurs plaidoiries
mais les technologies d'intelligence
artificielle redistribue les cartes
ce n'est pas tant la personnalité de
l'auteur qui est analysée mais celle de
son double informationnel au sens où
l'individu n'est que ce que les données
collectées sur lui dise de lui
une fois mise en résonance algorithmique
avec celle des autres prévenus dans
d'autres procès vous connaissez
l'expression être au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment avec l'ia cette
expression prend une portée différente
l'endroit et le moment sont déjà là
enfoui dans notre passé dans nos
relations de notre environnement prêt à
parler si la récurrence statistiques et
les corrélations le permettent de notre
affaire les données disponibles sur
notre homme navigation web activités sur
les réseaux environnements physiques et
numériques donnent l'image et le profil
de l'individu peu stables peu fiable
capable d'une certaine propension pour
la violence d'une certaine défiance
vis-à-vis de l'autorité
et sur cette base notamment la décision
est rendue
il est condamné à de la prison ferme
les excuses prononcées à l'audience et
les regrets qui semblait sincère n'ont
pas pesé lourd face aux prédictions
algorithmique tous drapés qu'elles sont
de leur manteau d'objectivité alors un
tel procès est il possible en france
la loi ne permet pas de prendre en
compte des analyses prédictives pour
rendre une décision de justice mais aux
états unis
ces analyses sont monnaie courante avec
les technologies dia tout l'enjeu et
qu'elle serve le bien commun et en
matière de justice
on a besoin des juges des procureurs des
avocats mais aussi des ingénieurs et
donc de vous et si vous le décidez sa
peut être votre défi notre défi je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]